تم بيع 30 فيلًا أفريقيًا بريًا صغيرًا تم أسرهم
وإرسالها إلى الصين لملء
المتنزهات وحدائق الحيوانات ، ولكن سيتم
كسرها أولاً هنا ، فيديو الهاتف الخلوي هذا هو
نظرة حصرية على آخر شحنة
من زيمبابوي في قفص من قفص معدني
، علامات المعاناة واضحة  قبل أسابيع فقط ،
كان هناك بين المجموعات العائلية
في حديقة وان جيا الوطنية ، قاموا
بفصل الصغار ليسوا الأصغر سناً ولكن
الفيل الصغير عن بقية
القطيع ويقول العلماء إن الفيل
حيوانات اجتماعية بشكل لا يصدق
يطورون روابط مدى الحياة ومن خلال
تمزيقهم  بعيدًا عن
عائلاتهم وإرسالهم إلى بلد أجنبي
، يقولون إنه أمر
مؤلم للغاية بالنسبة للفيل الذي يذهب
والفيل الذي يبقى على الرغم من هذه
المخاوف ، أصبحت التجارة بعد الآن
قانونية ولكن هذه النافذة تغلق
قواعد جديدة تمنع الشحنات الخارجية
من دول مثل زيمبابوي  تدخل حيز
التنفيذ الكامل في نهاية نوفمبر ،
يقول مسؤولو حديقة بابلي إنهم
سيلتزمون بهذه القواعد الجديدة  هناك المزيد من
الشفافية بعد الآن ، لكن مفتش حقوق الحيوان
كريسبين تشاكا دايا يقول إنه
رأى بالفعل تحولًا نحو السرية ،
هناك شيء غير صحيح خلال العام الماضي ،
منع المسؤولون فريقه من
دخول المتنزه بدعوى أنهم بحاجة إلى
تصاريح خاصة لم تكن مطلوبة بالفعل
ويخشى أن  لن تنتهي مبيعات الخنازير بالفعل ،
سأذهب تحت الأرض ، كيف كان الأمر
وكأنني أُبعدني ، أنا في
مفتش معين من قبل الحكومة ، وقد حان
موعد أذهاننا لنرى رفاهية
تلك الحيوانات التي لا تنتمي إلى
المنتزهات الوطنية  تنتمي إلى
شعب زيمبابوي ، لذا لدينا الآن إحداثيات نظام تحديد المواقع العالمي (GPS)
للمكان الذي نعتقد
أنه تم الاحتفاظ فيه بهذه الأفيال ، وهناك حوالي 30
فيلًا تم شحنها إلى الصين
تسببت في غضب عالمي
ناشطون في مجال حقوق الحيوان ، وأخبرتنا مصادر المتنزهات
أنه بعيدًا عن بوابة الازدهار هذه
تُركت الأفيال في الخلف وكانت
تستعد لإرسالها بعيدًا ،
وذهبنا إلى الإدارة
ورُفض الدخول مرارًا وتكرارًا ، وأخبرونا أنه
لا يوجد شيء  انظر لكنهم
وافقوا على مقابلة أمام الكاميرا
لماذا تبيع زيمبابوي الأفيال إلى الصين
كجزء من خطتنا الإدارية
لدينا رينجرز في هذه المجموعة الذين يقضون
21 يومًا في الأدغال لحماية هذه
الحيوانات وليس لديهم زي موحد
ليس لديهم  أحذية ليس لديهم خيام
وليس لديهم طعام كسلطة ،
نحن نعتقد أن الأفيال يجب أن
تدفع مقابل الصيانة
التي يجب عليهم أيضًا دفعها مقابل حمايتهم ،
إنه أحد العناصر التي تنعكس على الدولار
أن حماية الأفيال البرية في زيمبابوي
هي  بعيدًا عن التأكد من أن
الأفيال تموت أكثر من 200 في
الأشهر القليلة الماضية فقط بسبب
الجفاف الشديد الذي ضرب المنطقة في موسم الجفاف هذا ،
تعاني الأفيال في البرية
أيضًا ، لكن Ranger Oscars abanda
يقول إنه من الأفضل ترك الطبيعة تأخذ
مجراها وأنت تعتقد  من الجيد أن
يتم إرسال بعض الأفيال بعيدًا إلى حدائق الحيوان في الصين
وباكستان والولايات المتحدة  لا ، لا أعتقد أنه من
الحكمة أن تفخر ببلدنا
هو حيواناتنا للأطفال ثم
الأطفال ، لكن هذه الأفيال المأخوذة من
زيمبابوي تظل محاصرة بعيدًا عن المنزل
David McKenzie CNN kwangji